something that happened later instead of
sooner and it was something that
i didn't think was going to happen at
all for a very good reason that was
addressed
in the transaction that occurred on
sunday
yannick way disgruntled jacksonville
jaguars defensive end
traded to the minnesota vikings traded
for
a second round pick next year and a
fifth round pick in 2022 that can
upgrade to a
third round pick i have a feeling that
that may hinge on whether or not he
signs a long-term deal but i don't know
the terms yet
that would bump it up to a third round
pick chris
i initially was blown away
by this news because i didn't think
anyone was going to trade
sure for 17.778 million and give up the
value the jaguars wanted because the
jaguars attitude was we're not trading
this guy
unless we get what we want just like
with jaylen ramsey between jaylen ramsey
and yannick and gawkway
two first round picks a second round
pick a fifth round pick a fourth round
pick and the fifth round pick can become
a third round pick they've gotten a haul
for these two guys
they don't move guys unless they get
what they want they got what they wanted
and they got what they wanted very
simply because yannick and goku
gave up 5.7
million in salary that was
locked and loaded for 2020 all he had to
do
was hold his nose and spend one more
year with the jaguars
17.788 now i heard yesterday it was
thirteen five that he dropped two which
was stunning enough
multiple reports last night said it was
12 and the vikings can still tag him
in 2021 he didn't even get that removed
as part of giving up
almost a third of his salary one night i
could i still can't believe that i've
talked to people around the league like
how in the hell does this happen
and there's this lingering sense out
there that before penn gets put to paper
he's gonna change his mind and rip it up
and say screw it i'm just gonna stay in
jacksonville
for 17.7 million well i mean i i i
wouldn't be shocked i mean i'm with you
mike i was sitting there going wow
man minnesota taking a risk here wow
this is unbelievable but then of course
yeah you hear that he takes the pay cut
and all that let me ask you this first
off mike if minnesota was the franchise
in la
next year it would still be above the
norm
like him dropping the price tag down has
nothing to do with it right
well well well the franchise tender for
any player
is the base value of the tag yeah
a 20 raise over what he made the prior
year whichever is greater now here's the
problem right
he was looking at north of 21 million
for next year which means the jaguars
were going to let him hit the open
market they're not going to keep them
around for 21 million unless he has 28
sacks
now in minnesota 12 million is his
salary
so the 20 kicker gets him to 14
4 which coincidentally is the annual
average on the neil hunter contract
we'll talk about him coming up
most likely the base value for the
franchise tag for defensive ends will be
more than 14-4
however remember we've talked about this
if the salary cap goes down and we
expect it to go down that drags down the
base
level of the franchise tenders because
it's driven by percentage of cap
i don't think it's going to go from 17-7
south of 14-4 yeah right but if the cap
goes down that number's going down
and and yannick and gawkway is going
from 17
7 8 8 plus 21 million
and more than 21 million so it's about
38 39 million for a two-year haul
he's looking at 12 plus let's let's just
throw a dart and say 15. yeah
27 million over two years now again that
second year of the tag was never going
to happen
but he would have been on the open
market right six months away
he's six months away from going wherever
he wants the problem is if the cap goes
down next year they're
going to be a huge uh rush to pay free
agents but but he's still now he's at
the mercy of the vikings
to possibly be tagged again in a much
lower number yeah or sign a long-term
deal based on this law
look i i i'm serious i
uh either yannick and gawkwood just
absolutely despises jacksonville i think
that's me
how can you despise it so much that you
give up nearly six million dollars to
get out i don't know either
i'd move anywhere for six million
dollars for one year yeah i probably
even live in greenwich i would too
though i'm with you i don't know if i
would have changed my mind
i would have stuck it to the
jacksonville jaguars been like all right
well yep here i am guys
let's go 17 million dollars a year
franchise i certainly wouldn't have made
that decision
but again we don't know everything
that's got on here
or maybe yannick and gawkway's side of
the story regardless like
we're very clear that he doesn't want to
be with the jacksonville jaguars there's
never
been like any inkling in the news or
anybody i've talked to in football that
have been like uh
i think this might work out and it's
just you know it's a little tense right
now but
he'll be back there i don't know mike i
never got that inkling from anybody
like that this was over the relationship
was severed
and that they were gonna try to trade
him now you know hey the rest of this
we'll see and i mean you're right mike
i mean i i don't know maybe he will have
second thoughts as he's going to
minnesota and about to put pen to paper
and start to go
man am i really going to get give up 5
million
but regardless just from the pure
football aspect of it
and especially with the minnesota
vikings let's just hit on that first
hey this was a big time move and i think
a much needed move
i mean we talked about your minnesota
vikings and the power rankings before
we talked about the defense and yeah
there's some potential and
two young stud corners and we know the
safeties are good
but the young stud corners are unproven
you know they haven't done anything yet
in football we know the linebackers are
good
and then other than danielle hunter you
know who
you think well i got well done right 40.
well you were there
well done but other than that for a
defense that's
made its name with a fierce front four
under mike zimmer
there's nobody that people know there's
no household name other than than daniel
hunter
and with michael pierce opting out and
linville joseph gone
you know there was a huge void there and
i think that
between that and the corner position and
some of those questions i think
minnesota and zimmer realized
we got to do something here or our
defense is going to get
you know steamrolled this year and and
gawkway actually younger
than daniel hunter who uh has the
all-time
record for most sacks before turning 25
he turned 25
during the 2020 season and coach mike
zimmer
made it clear yesterday they wanted
another pass rusher they've been looking
for another pass rusher for quite a
while
i think that's important when you have a
young secondary if the trade goes
through then i think that adds
to what we can do and again until it's
done
it technically is never done and
up to and including the moment where the
pen gets put on paper the player can say
i'm just not doing this
and if yannick and gawkway wakes up this
morning assuming he didn't sign the
paperwork yesterday if he wakes up this
morning and says you know what the hell
with this
then he's back to where he was and where
he was
is in a position to make 17.788 million
for one more year with the jaguars and
then become a free agent next year
i'm stu i i'd love to know the inside
story on how this went down because to
me there's no plausible explanation
for giving up 5.788 million dollars for
one more
season with the jacksonville jaguars and
then you become a free agent next year
because they're not gonna keep you
around
for 21 million they're not going to do
it
uh and maybe they tag you next year to
be cute and they have the cap space but
how do you have
if the cap's down to 175 million how are
you going to tie up 21 million plus
in a guy who doesn't want to be there
yeah so i i i'm
i'm stunned but from the vikings
perspective i was stunned because
we hear all the time they got cap
problems they got cap problems you know
anytime anyone says a team has cap
problems
the reality is cat problems can be dealt
with yeah we went through a long period
of time in the nfl where most of the
teams had cap problems
and all that a cap problem means it's
like a math problem when you have a math
problem what do you do
you solve it when you have a cap problem
what do you do you solve it
that's it right now look i mean yeah you
you could get yourself into a spot where
you actually have to cut players and
you have no way out of this maze i mean
that's possible there are some
unsolvable problems for the most part
teams know how to
figure out how to come up with cap space
and when the guy's only taking 12
million
that becomes a way that you can you can
much more easily come up with the cap
space
for the player for one year and 12
million but uh you know i'm sure we'll
see
the vikings have restructured contracts
move some money around to create this
space for yannick and gawkway and it
shows that they have the need yeah
everything griffin-time need yannick and
gawkway steps in
and now they've got you know we drafted
the best pass rushing duos a couple of
weeks ago chris i think we have to
reshuffle the deck
and i think in gakway and hunter would
be in that in that list
yeah i think they certainly would be i
mean there's no doubt you know the the
the reason you got to make that move too
and again you and me follow football and
everything but
you know most just like the everyday fan
or whatever
you you can't name another defensive
lineman on the minnesota vikings right
now on that roster
and then you know to add to that right
the big thing is and they have some
young talented guys i'm not trying to
discredit them i'm just talking about
household names guys that we know
can create mismatches an offense has to
oh wait we can't leave our guy
one-on-one we have to help
out in protection over there you know
daniel hunter was the only guy
and when your defense is based i mean
when your team is based around
defense and now the run game wow
you're going to have a you know below
average front four and play that style
of football that's not gonna work
and mike zimmer i mean he's smart he
realizes that and i think the other
thing too you got to take into account
is mike zimmer
traditionally not a huge blitz
defensive coordinator you know he's not
the kind of guy that's like rex ryan
or some of these other guys who yeah
he's gonna send six guys to one side and
do all these crazy things no mike zimmer
he's kind of got a formula in which he
does and yeah mike blitz five but
mainly he wants to rush four and drop
seven and play coverage or maybe drop
you know rush
five and drop six do something like that
but within that
you gotta have like two stellar pass
rushers if that's gonna be your formula
consistently and that's what's made them
so good you know through these
the zimmer era is because they've been
able to do that and it's kept them in
the playoff conversation
and i don't i think they were in deep
trouble unless they got something uh
some kind of caliber player like they
did in in gawkway
are we in agreement that the two most
important positions in football
are passer and pass rusher yes
yeah i would agree with that i do yes a
hundred percent vikings have
60 million dollars in a lot of space
tied up this year we're not cap space
average salary value between kirk
cousins at
33 million per year average to neil
hunter at 14
4 and now yannick and gawkway at 12
again the cap numbers are different
because of the structure but it's nearly
60 million between those two players an
average salary tied up
in in the two most important positions
in football yeah i i mean
it's a lot of money and again i think it
goes into another thing we talked about
with minnesota a little bit they're a
little
top-heavy the football team we've had
this discussion before too
you know and this is going to add to
that that problem a little bit
but i also think minnesota's in this
weird window right now mike and i don't
know you correct me if i'm wrong
it's like oh the shelf life of this past
team that we just saw it kind of ended
but they don't want to rebuild because
mike zimmer's you know
he's got a few years left they just
redid kirk cousins and gave him
more years so i think they look at it
and go wait we kind of have these two
mainstays that have
gotten us where we are here do we really
want to start back at scratch
and now they have to make this type of
move and maybe leverage the future a
little bit because
they think hey the time is now with
zimmer and kirk cousins and some of
these younger guys that they're going to
be able to strike
one of the questions is how good is
yannick and gawkway you know the concern
is he's a one-trick pony he's a pass
rusher
but he's not a run stop right and and so
you know he's only going to help in
certain circumstances like third and
long or
second and long uh is he a guy they're
going to be able to count on
if opposing offenses decide to run the
ball straight at him
well i i think that's a big question he
is not a big guy i mean he to me looks
like a guy that has to work to
you know keep his weight up in a lot of
ways so
you know this was something that that
you know i know we talked about a lot
even you know going into this yannick
and gawkway
i don't want to play for the jags or
whatever else last year
yeah is he in the class of a you know a
dexter lawrence to me
uh or not you know demarcus lawrence of
the dallas cowboys and some of those
other top paid guys at the position
no i think you know he has pass rush
elite skills in a lot of ways but
yeah he is a one-trick pony that way
send him out wide he wants to rush
around the edge
speed wise and yeah they're going to
have to do some things on defense at
times to
maybe help him out or be at least aware
of him in the run game to know
ooh you know this isn't going to be good
a tight end and a tackle on yannick and
gawkway double teaming him
there's an issue there we might need to
push the linebackers over or spin down
the safety
uh i think that's a very real question
about his game
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports